le Hamas est un mouvement de résistance
Gérald haranin saisit la justice contre
Daniel auonau pour apologie du
terrorisme bien sûr Daniel auono un
député de la France insoumise et la
France insoumise bah c'est c'est un jour
une une boulette on a envie de dire la
France insoumise qui s'enfond en cor euh
qui bah on comprend pas ça veut dire je
sais pas si ils essaient de faire le
buzz tous les jours elle était chez
Jean-Jacques BOURD il lui pose la
question plusieurs fois elle affirme que
c'est un mouvement de résistance et pas
un mouvement terroriste évidemment
énorme polémique derrière le ministre de
l'Intérieur et il a bien fait je pense à
saisi la justice contre la député pour
apologie du terrorisme et la question se
pose de plus en plus la France insoumise
est-elle un danger pour la France c'est
ce que disent de plus en plus de gens
c'est ce que je pense je vous le dis je
pense c'est vraiment un danger on le
voit on a vu la dérive de la France
insoumise semaine après semaine et je
men rappelle de de de cette cet échange
entre Gérard daranin et Louis Boyard
d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée ou encore avec
d'autres députés de la France insoumise
on avait jamais vu ça avant hein je vous
dis avant la France insoumise quand ils
sont depuis qu'ils sont arrivés et
qu'ils sont nombreux à l'Assemblée
nationale ça a jamais été autant le
bordel on va dire on va appeler les on
on va on va dire les mots alors on va en
parler dans un instant regardez ce
qu'elle a dit Daniel obonau mais moi ce
que je pense sur la France insoumise
c'est que justement je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas les clés et que ce sont
vraiment des personnes qui ne
travaillent pas et qui ne connaissent
pas leur dossier et je pense que c'est
le gros problème de la France insoumise
ils font plus de télé plus de médias que
d'aller un petit peu travailler leur
dossier et donc ils arrivent souvent en
émission ils n'y connaissent rien ils
sont comme des lapins pris dans les
phares et ils disent n'importe quoi on
l'a vu avec mathil Panau qui s'est
retrouvé à être interrogé on a vu on a
je vous l'ai dit dernière fois on aurait
dit moi au tableau à l'époque en 4e2 on
savait pas ce que lui demander les gens
ils ne travaillent pas ils ne
connaissent rien en fait le problème
c'est qu'ils sont que à la recherche du
buzz et connaissent pas leur dossier
donc forcément derrière et ben ça crée
des Bad de buzz parce que ils essaient
en plus de faire les malins donc quand
tu sais rien et que tu fais le malin et
ben tu tombes dans le ravin voilà merci
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'avez pas
qualifié le Hamas de de mouvement
terroriste parce que pour vous c'est un
mouvement de résistance je cherche
l'explication
oui c'est c'est nécessaire
d'AV c'est nécessaire d'avoir estce que
c'est un mouvement de résistance c'est
nécessaire d'avoir des clarifications
parce que les mots sont important de
clarification justement est-ce que c'est
un mouvement de résistance c'est un
groupe politique islamiste qui a une
branche armée et qui s'inscrit dans les
formations politiques
palestiniennes a pour objectif la
libération de de la Palestine et qui
résiste à une occupation c'est un
mouvement de résistance oui et oui c'est
un mouvement de
résist qui se définit comme tel et qui
est reconnu comme tel par les les
instances internationales c'est ce que
vous
pensez bourin excellent en tout cas
voilà vraiment il est est très très bon
mais Daniel obono non mais je vais vous
dire je en veux même pas Daniel obono
enfin j' en veux oui j' en veux pour sa
méconnaissance encore du sujet je pense
que c'est ce sont excusez-moi ce sont
des ce sont des guignoles voilà la
France insoumise ce sont des guignoles
qui font qui se sont retrouvés là par
hasard qui ont eu un chef qui est voilà
qui a qui a plus qui a qui qui qui a
voilà qui a un certain bagû et qui
arrive à faire passer quelques idées
mais derrière il n'y a que des guignoles
et c'est ça le problème et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je vois les déclarations
de rquel garido d'Alexis Corbière qui
sont un petit peu plus cérébrés que les
autres on voit que même eux se disent
bon il va falloir qu'on fasse quelque
chose et qu'on prenne de la distance
avec eux j'ai eu la chance de travailler
avec Raquel garido et Alexis Corbière et
je me sens je m'entendait très bien avec
eux ça se passait très bien ce sont des
gens qui ont les idées qu'ils ont et il
y a plein de choses sur les quel
d'ailleurs j'étais d'accord avec eux rel
garido Alex mais qui ne sont pas dans la
recherche du buzz permanent qui ne sont
pas dans une dérive comme les
aujourd'hui la France insoumise et comme
le sont Mathide Panau Louis Boyard
Daniel obonau qui sont juste qui sont là
par hasard qui n'y connaissent rien et
qui sont excusez-moi des guignoles voilà
je le dis sont des gugus Gil verd
qu'est-ce que tu en penses bon sur ce
que dit Madame obono c'est scandaleux
parce qu'il faut savoir que le mouvement
de résistance c'est ainsi que le Hamas
lui-même se définit mouement de
résistance donc elle reprend la
terminologie du Hamas c'est un groupe
terroriste en con Ren non mais elle
était sur Wikipédia vous croyez quoi ah
oui mais inacable même paré d'ailleurs
tu as raison gr moi je crois pas je suis
pas d'accord moi je pense
que groupe terroriste en France donc je
trouve que le ministre a très bien fait
on est dans l'apologie du terroristme
c'est scandaleux inacceptable après sur
la France insommise Estelle un danger je
réponds nonou je dis moi je pense que
oui parce que elle est en train de
sortir du champ démocratique et que la
responsabilité d'un homme po que ou
d'une femme politique c'est de dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont et personne
n'invente le fait que le Hamas est un
groupe terroriste elle est en train de
légitimer un groupe terroriste au nom
d'une cause qui elle peut-être juste
mais ce sont deux choses différentes on
l'a dit 50 fois le peuple palestinien
c'est une chose et un groupe terroriste
Hamas a commis une exaction terrible la
plus forte depuis la Choa s'en est une
autre donc on peut pas on peut pas
confondre et on peut pas légitimer et
elle doit avoir des mots clairs don ils
sont en train de sortir du champ démocra
TW j'ai vu passer moi hier qui disait je
suis israélien je suis palestinien je ne
suis pas Hamas
voà voilà on adore exactement on adore
derrière le groupe Alfi donc à
l'assemblée a donné une conférence de
presse pour venir à scous donc bah eux
ce sont les pompiers PIR ou ouais il
mett le FE après derrière il essayent d'
l'éteindre voilà et vous allez voir
c'est encore pire il dit ce n'est pas
exactement ce qu'elle a dit la LFI sont
actuellement dans des sables mouvants et
le problème c'est qu' encore des des des
des des conneries qui dépassent donc il
parlent encore et ils ouvrent leur
gueule tous les jours c'est devenu
insupportable enfin cette branche de la
franceoumis que les gens disent oui j'ai
moi y a la France insoumise je vous l'ai
dit Alexis corbierre à quel garido ils
ont travaillé avec moi voilà mais la
France insoumise je vous le dis ça
devient n'importe quoi et je pense que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon va tout droit dans le
mur Jean-Pierre alkabach n'est plus là
mais s'il avait été là et s'il avait été
aujourd'hui en face de jeanluc Mélenchon
il lu aurait dit quelle couleur vous
vous le voulez le mur le mur dans lequel
vous allez et c'est dramatique et je
pense que la France insoumise est
dangereuse au début on en rigolé
aujourd'hui on en rigole plus parce que
ça devient de plus en plus dramatique et
G Verde je comprends que ce soit vos
amis mais sachez que ils sont dangereux
regardez amis sont vos amis je sais pas
exactement ce que Daniel auono a dit
elle a répondu que certains le voient
comme un mouvement de résistance après
plusieurs questions de Monsieur Bourdin
pour lui faire dire cela et nous
n'apportons aucun soutien au Hamas qui
n'est pas un mouvement de résistance je
l'ai déjà dit le Hamas est le produit de
décennies de guerre et il est le produit
conscient volontaire également d'une
certaine politique du gouvernement d'
israélien alors on va revoir donc
l'extrit de Daniel obano qui n' non mais
attendez attendez parce que on va revoir
l'extrrait de Daniel obono qui n'assume
pas avoir qualifié le Hamas de mouvement
de résistance plutôt que de mouvement
terroriste au cours de son interview
vous allez voir que ce n'est pas arrivé
une seule fois dans l'extrait mais cinq
fois donc bon la France insoumise là les
gars il va falloir faire une autre
conférence de presse ça va commencer à
vous coûter cher hein ces conneries je
sa pas d'où il sort l'oseille en tout
cas il va falloir aller chercher je
pense chez Monsieur Mélenchon qui vous
donne un petit billet en plus qu'il va
falloir faire une autre conférence de
presse demain les ché regardez pourquoi
est-ce que vous n'avez pas qualifié le
Hamas de de mouvement terroriste parce
que pour vous c'est un mouvement de
résistance je cherche l'explication
oui c'est c'est nécessaire d' de
résistance c'est nécessaire d'avoir
est-ce que c'est un mouvement de
résistance c'est nécessaire d'avoir des
clarifications parce que les mots sont
moi je de clarification justement est-ce
que c'est un mouvement de résistance
c'est un groupe politique islamiste qui
a une branche armée et qui s'inscrit
dans les formations politiques
palestiniennes euh a pour objectif la
libération de de la
pales qui résiste à une occupation c'est
un mouvement de résistance oui et oui
c'est un mouvement de résistance est que
vous qui se définit comme tel et qui est
reconnu comme tel par les les instances
international de résistance c'est
il pas on dirait on on dirait moi l'oral
du bac on dirait qu'elle récite un truc
elle est complètement à la ramasse non
mais elle est complètement à la ramasse
je vous dis et même même je vois
Jean-Jacques qui est excellent
d'ailleurs Jean-Jacques Bourdin même lui
ça le fait rire il se dit mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette bande de gugus non
mais franchement oui mais moi je je suis
pas sûr qu'elle soit complètement à la
ramasse ah là là je vous dis là elle
récite un texte elle sait même pas ce
qu'elle dit je suis pas sûre qu'elle
soit ignorante je sû que elle soit
guignole moi je pense que c'est un
calcul politique je pense que c'est une
provocation non mais moi c'est un moment
non et je pense que alors pourquoi
chaque fois qu'il y a un terroriste
islamiste il ne prononce pas le mot que
ce soit Mélenchon que ce soit elle que
ce soit madame Panau que ce soit
monsieur porte que ce soit monsieur
Boyard pourquoi ça impossible monsieur
Boyard mathde Panau et cetera je vais
vous dire autant parler des les pied
niclés oui mais sauf que si on dit que
c'est des pied niclés et si on dit que
ce sont des guignoles en fait ça veut
dire que quelque part malgré tout on les
prend VO exactement on les prend pas
sérieux ce sont des clown mais sauf que
ces clown ils ont un poids et ces clown
on les écoute et moi je vais citer
quelqu'un que par parfois les gens
n'aiment pas beaucoup mais moi je trouve
que il est très très bien c'est l'imam
de Drancy monsieur chalgoumi qui dit
quand les élus de la France insoumise ne
savent pas désigner ce qu'est le
terrorisme ils trahissent et prennent en
otage les musulmans et les quartiers de
notre pays et bien moi je pense que
Madame auono en faisant ça c'est
exactement ce qu'elle fait et et c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'ils sont
totalement irresponsables très très
dangereux et participent justement à
importer un conflit qu'on ne maîtrise
pas et hier et MO a tout dit
parfaitement bien un un confliit dont on
n' pas tous les tenants et les
aboutissants nous on veut deux é voilà
on veut la paix c'est tout ce qu'on veut
et je pense que eux c'est pas ce qu'ils
veulent ils importent un conflit et on a
pas les tenants les aboutissants et ils
veulent absolument que ça se passe mal
ici chez nous je P alors je vais vous
dire ce que veul ce que veut la France
pour moi ils veulent le chaos
ici toutes les façons c'est ce qu'ils
veulent depuis le début ils ont toujours
dit
voilàt démocratiquement ils arrivaient
pas il que la France explose en disant
peut-être que du chaos on arrivera à s
du jeu et on se radicalise comme ça on
peutème Géraldine je sais alors il y en
a qui arrivent à s'en sortir et à faire
croire euh voilà qui qui savent de trois
trucs Mélenchon je vous dis il s'en sort
bien il y en a deux trois comme
ça ou exactement mais parce que
Mélanchon bon il arrive à trouver mais
le reste on le voit c'est en fait c'est
c'est les sousdoué passe le bac madame
est très clair non mais les sousdou
c'est les sousdoués font de la politique
excusez-moi non mais c'est une
catastrophe non mais franchement on
dirait moi je vous dis à chaque fois je
la vois quand madame obonau n'allez pas
faire une émission vous allez faire
jean-jaces savez je-jacqu Bourdin il va
vous titiller vous savez que
Jean-Jacques Bourdin il va il va vous
interroger franchement n allez pas n
allez pas vous savez très bien qu' va
vous piégerès bien
ce déjà oui mais c'est parce qu'elle n'y
connait rien excusez-moi cro j'ai
travaillé avec Louis Boyard
excusez-moiard on prenait ici pour
amuser la galerie il savait juste faire
la différence cétait on l' pris il nous
a dit que c un ancien dealer écoutez on
espère qui va retourner à ses premiers
amours non mais elle a une grille de
lecture du monde et elle sait très bien
ce qu'elle dit je pense pas du tout
qu'elle a été piégée ou qu'elle ou
qu'elle se dise mince je suis perdu je
ne sais pas ce que je veux dire et
cetera elle sait pertinemment ce qu'elle
dit elle sait par ailleurs qu'elle dit
un mensonge quand elle dit que le ramas
est considéré comme une organisation
militaire ou je ne sais plus en faitonn
internationalement voilà l'ONU et et
l'Union européenne la consid comme une
organisation terroriste donc elle sait
pertinemment qu'elle dit quelque chose
qui est faux elle sait voilà c'est une
il propose une vision du monde leur
vision du monde qui est pour vous ils
sont dangereux bien sûou ils sont
dangereux et puis cy on voit bien depuis
plusieurs jours c'est une cacophonie
incroyable qu'à chaque fois qu'il y en a
un qui parle ah bah en fait on n pas
compris ah mais si mais on a quand même
dit le mot terroriste ah non mais en
fait on va refaire une conférence de
presse pour dire c'est pas tout à fait
ce que vous avez
compris illustre quoi ça illustre que
d'abord un ils sont pas tous d'accord
parce que c'est ça la réalité de la
France insoumise c'est qu' y a plus de
chef on a l'impression aussi et je vous
le dis moi moi je vais vous dire un truc
il y a eu un complément d'enquête sur
la compagne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sopia
chiricou exactement Chikirou Chikirou
pardon Chikirou merci je pense je je
vous pose la question est-ce qu'il
serait possible parce que vous l'aviez
dit ici il était prévu depuis longtemps
il n'avait pas été fait une fois que
vous l'avez dit il a été programmé
est-ce qu'il est possible que il a été
poussé par l'autre branche de la LFI
parce qu'on a l'impression que dans la
LFI ils veulent tous prendre la place de
Jean-Luc M et qui sentent que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est en fin de parcours ce que
je pense c'est que au moment où on s'en
était parlé ça correspondait à un moment
où ça ne fonctionnait pas d'un point de
vue politique et comme à l'intérieur de
LFI il y a une il y a une sission qui
s'opère depuis plusieurs mois c'est
aujourd'hui plus facile de raconter
cette histoire où et je pense qu'ils ont
donné des éléments à complément
d'enquête l'autre manche évidemment mais
après ça c'est aussi un fonctionnement
journalistique ass fré complments ont
tout à fait le droit je pas
bien sûr parce que ils y sont all les
complément d'enquête dessus ils avaient
des ils avaient quand même ils avaient
des des éléments mais sur des éléments
sur des éléments concernant les comptes
de campagne de Mélenchon qui était quand
même connu depuis 2018 bien sûr bon je
je pense qu'il y a des choses qui
auraient pu être dites avant mais je
referme cette parenthèse polémique la
réalité c'est que il y a une sission qui
qui qui qui qui s'opère depuis un
certain nombre de mois avec Ruffin avec
otin qui veent tout prix déboulonner la
statue du chef parce que il leur fait
honte d'une certaine façon et Ruffin il
faut le dire C dernières pris de es ont
été très clair ce que j'ai envie de dire
aussi je pense que la gauche elle doit
être mieux représentée c'est pas
possible que dans le coner
actu par qu qu'
prage des g de qu aujourd'hui tant que
la LFI sera aussi présente et qu'il aura
pas quelqu'un qui va émerger à gauche et
qui va essayer de mettre la France
insoumise de côté personne n'émergera je
vous le dis voilà et pour l'instant je
vois pas quelqu'un émerg
à gauche l'stant c'est la France
insomise qui prend tout l'esace prend
tout l'esace a dit qu'il voulait un
nouveau front populaire ou oui mais oui
bien sûr Mo aussi moi aussi je ve un
nouveau plateau allez merci non mais
c'est je l'adore mais bon c'est bon moi
aussi moi aussi je veux une nouvelle
voiture allez